you were one of the
lawyers who represented the hollywood
producer harvey
weinstein in advance of a sexual assault
trial
for this harvard forced you to step down
as faculty deans
you and your wife of winter pals can you
tell the story of this saga
from first deciding to represent harvey
weinstein
to the interesting complicated events
that followed
yeah sure so i got a call one morning
from a colleague at
the harvard law school who uh asked if
uh i would consent to taking a call from
from harvey uh he wanted to meet me and
uh and chat with me about representing
him i said yes and
um one thing led to another uh i
drove out to connecticut uh where he was
staying and met with him and
some of his advisors and then a day or
two later
i decided to take the case this would
have been
back in uh january of 2019
uh i believe so the sort of cases i have
a
very small practice most of my time is
teaching and
and writing uh but uh i tend to take
cases that
most uh deem to be uh impossible
uh uh i take the challenging sorts of
cases and
and this was uh fit the bill it was
quite
challenging in the sense that uh
everyone
had uh prejudged the case when i say
everyone i just mean the
the general sentiment and the public uh
uh had the case
prejudged even though
the specific allegations did not regard
uh the
any of the people in the um
in the new yorker that's the new yorker
article that sort of uh
uh exposed uh everything that was going
on
allegedly with with harvey so i decided
to uh
to take the case and i did
is there a philosophy behind you taking
on these
very difficult cases like is it a set of
principles is it just your love of the
law
or is it is there like set of principles
why you
take on the cases yeah i do i take on
i'd like to take on hard cases
and i'd like to take on the cases that
uh
are with unpopular uh defendants
unpopular
clients um and with respect to the
latter that's where harvey
weinstein fell uh it's
because uh we need
lawyers and good lawyers to take the
unpopular cases
because that those sorts of cases
determine what sort of criminal justice
system we have
uh if we don't protect the rights and
the liberties of those whom the society
deems to be the least and the last
the unpopular client and that's the the
camel's nose under the tent
if we let the camel's nose under the
temp the entire tent is going to
collapse
that is to say if we short circuit
the rights of a client like harvey
weinstein
then the next thing you know someone
will be at your door
knocking it down and violating your
rights there's a there's a certain
creep there with respect to um the
way in which the the state will respect
the civil rights and civil liberties
of people and these are the sorts of
cases that that tested
so you know for example uh there's a
there there was a young man many many
years ago named ernesto miranda
uh by all accounts he was not a likable
guy
he was uh you know three-time
knife thief and not a likable guy but
lawyers stepped up and took his case and
because of that we now have the
miranda uh warnings you have the right
to remain silent those
those warnings that uh officers are
are forced to give to people so it is
through these cases that we
express oftentimes the best values in
our criminal justice system so i
i proudly take on these sorts of cases
in order to vindicate not only the
individual rights of the person whom i'm
representing but the rights of citizens
writ large who most of whom
do not experience the criminal justice
system and
it's partly because of lawyers who
take on these sorts of cases and
establish
rules that protect us from
average everyday ordinary concrete
citizens as
from a psychological perspective just
you as a human
is there is there fear is there stress
from all the pressure because if you're
facing i mean the whole point a
difficult case
especially in the latter that you
mentioned of the going against popular
opinion
you have the eyes of millions
potentially looking at you with anger
as you try to defend uh you know this
these set of laws that this country is
built on no it doesn't stress me out
particularly
it uh you know it sort of comes with the
the territory i try not to
get uh too excited in either
direction so a big part of my practice
is
a wrongful convictions and i um
i've gotten uh over 6 000 people
out of prison who've been wrongfully
incarcerated and
a subset of those people have been
convicted and you know if people have
been in jail
20 30 uh years who have gotten out and
those are the sorts of cases where
people
uh praise you and and and that sort of
thing
and so look i i do
uh the work that i do i'm proud of the
work that i do
and in that sense i'm uh sort of a
part-time taoist
the expression reversal is the movement
of the dow uh so i don't get too high i
don't get too
low i just try to do my work and
represent people to the best of my
ability
you